Oh why are you hanging enemies a bit it
is yeah emperor Titus need the second
life dad and the dog brotherhood yes but
our work is just beginning approach me
and hear my word processors
how about what that was about but i'll
be out later than anything just [ __ ]
well i gotta kill a dragon
let's go sagging again ultimate dragon
shut any know the bow again ketchum
finger land
[ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
every time
it may be dead now but where did it come
from where did they come from yeah
Jeremy TV that hosted it may be dead now
where's it come from
back up
music crimes against Islander people
what stays your defense
I guess just [ __ ] times a night come in
Becca anyway
the thieves guild is made of blackbriar
interest you in some muscle injury
you
native gold or they have some work for
you well well if you happen occur on it
you find this timer to be more than fair
sir well well if you haven't by the
height you actually got your aim sorry
this allowed is were thwarted some
thieves earned in our lifetime the dog
would exactly are we talking about here
yeah we do that tell me what you need
and I'll get more people on it badderson
of course you do chime of course you do
yeah he'll come in a day of course you
do haha there how much the dark of a
Friday treat buffering I've got all
arcane i hope the price is at least
little doubt and good luck with your
murders excellent thank you